i just want to ask an open-ended
question from you so it is now today's
what day today is the 11th okay
last year no two years ago
uh march 12th i'm in la for a board
meeting i think it was march 11th or
march 12th and that was the day when nba
shutdown nhl shutdown universal studios
shut down disney shutdown two years ago
tom your phone is making noise all that
stuff shut down
uh
and and it was like you turn on the tv
it's like you know and we're in beverly
hills hilton and my wife and i were
about to have a board meeting with the
kids
and that's when donovan mitchell got
coveted and he was upset at uh
touching all the microphones
and every board member of mine canceled
the meeting they didn't even come come
to the meeting from connecticut from
florida nobody showed the day that the
nba show and that was like the canary in
the coal mine when the nba shut down
everything was basically
they called me they said this is real
we're shutting it down we're not showing
up we're not having a board meeting
it's now been two years okay
and throughout the two years uh you know
a lot's happened we had a new president
the market went all the way down to i
don't know what the number was 16 17 18
000 came back up to 34 35 000.
uh we've had stimulus after stimulus
after stimulus that's been sent out
we've had
travel that's been restricted we've had
tsa reports on amount of people
traveling on a daily basis go from 2.4
2.5 million to 100 200 000 a day which
is absolutely insane warren buffett sold
out
his 10 or 11 shares in united american
delta and he just said he thinks this
system is going to be changing with
travel a company called zoom went from
being a company that we knew about to
all of a sudden overnight we're all
zooming we're all on zoom doing meetings
everything changed overnight
two years has passed
what have we learned in the last two
years specifically to what we thought
was
true two years ago to
the uh
you know um
not controversies to the contradictions
that we had well this is what this is
and this is what that is
two years later things have settled down
no one goes out worried about cobit new
york's even shutting down masks and a
lot of other people are shutting down
masks what have we learned last two
years there's a lot more coved now than
it was two years ago
why were so people so afraid two years
ago to not even get in the same room and
have a sales meeting but yet
now they're perfectly comfortable going
into an 80 000 state person stadium and
watching a pro football game
why
fear
fear is an unbelievable
human
emotion
and the fear has always been much
greater and out of proportion to the
reality if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]